the first anniversary of Sudan's
military takeover and thousands gathered
to demonstrate in the capital Khartoum
and other cities protesters demanding
the Army and its Rule and hand over
power to a civilian government
[Music]
we want to return to a democratic
civilian transition the Army should
return to the barracks and militia
groups should be dissolved we don't want
them to rule they should know they are
supposed to only preserve the country's
security not take over power
the coup ended a two-year transitional
government that was a result of a power
sharing agreement between the Army and
the pro-democracy group forces of
freedom and change or FFC the military
then deposed prime minister Abdullah
hamdulk and arrested several senior
government officials they were later
released and hamdurim stated before he
resigned in January the Takeover angered
many on the streets
we are out today to support the demand
of a civilian government that came as a
result of the Revolution it was leading
the country to a democracy we're not
against the Army as a whole just some
individuals the Army has been
politicized and if there are reforms
made to it we will not have any issues
because there is no country without an
army
the Takeover also created a political
turmoil as some parties sided with the
military in its power grab and others
condemned it with the African Union the
United Nations Mission here in Sudan and
the regional body intergovernmental
Authority for development have been
trying to broker a deal between the
political parties and the military
but that has so far failed to produce
results Security Forces use tear gas to
disperse protesters since the Takeover
more than 100 people have been killed
and hundreds injured in protests against
the military but that's not stop the
demonstrators
the Takeover has not produced a single
good thing the health and education
sector are deteriorating and there are
more tribal conflicts the social fabric
of Sudan has been destroyed
Sudan's Army has previously stated it
was stepping away from talks to allow
parties to reach a consensus on forming
a new government while that is yet to
happen those on the streets continue to
call for a return to civilian Rule
people Morgan Al Jazeera